[Music]
musician Dan Auerbach has a shelf full
of grammy awards for his work as
frontman for the Black Keys and as a
sought-after producer just yesterday he
released his second solo album waiting
on a song brand new tunes but with the
distinctively retro sound he's become
known for well here in perform in just a
moment but first I had a chance to sit
down with Dan at Electric Lady studios
here in New York when the Black Keys one
of rock's most popular garage acts took
a break after their last tour Akron born
frontman Dan Auerbach went back to his
adopted home in Nashville to recharge
and he began inviting local musicians
over to his studio easy I
so I started riding Monday through
Wednesday we'd ride all day long and
then Thursday through Saturday we'd
record and that's what we did every week
for how long I haven't stopped since
last summer I mean pretty much we I
write every week and record every week
how many songs you haven't a couple
hundred Wow well something something
better than others right
[Music]
some of the best are on our backs new
solo out this second
[Music]
our back is supported on the record by
some of Nashville's best musicians like
legendary songwriter John Prine and
legendary guitarist Wayne in what have
you gotten out of that whole process I
mean it's changed my life really I can't
wait to get to the studio every day so
that's a great feeling yeah it's like
Christmas every day when I get to go to
the studio with these guys I mean it is
almost like Field of Dreams it's like if
you build it they will come I didn't
know who they were when I built my
studio I didn't know these guys but I
built it in Nashville I kind of finally
met a whole group of people with the
same weird
addiction you know yes I mean these guys
are in their mid seventies they'll meet
need the studio 9:30 in the morning
we'll be there till 2:00 a.m. working
yeah and then I'll see in the next day
at 9:30 you know they'll bring coffee
hahaha it's leads to the inevitable
question is where does that leave the
keys I mean nothing has changed we're
just taking a break nice little vacation
they won't again
[Music]
the Black Keys broke out with the album
brothers in 2010 they've since scored
four number-one songs on the alternative
chart and on tour the band began selling
out major arenas like Madison Square
Garden but our Beck says heat and
drummer Patrick Carney grew weary of
life on the road it's hard when you go
and you become a rock star and you play
on these big stages I think it's easy to
forget that you know where you came from
how does that make you feel about going
back and being a rock star again well I
mean I've always kind of I've always
been apprehensive about all you know all
that stuff it always felt very unnatural
and me and Pat - I mean yeah we're not
rock stars and I think that's why people
kind of fell for us you know I mean yeah
those are gonna make it harder for you
to go back out there cuz you're enjoying
yeah so I'm sure it will yeah but it's
what I do it's what I've always done I
mean it's hard for anybody the older you
get to want to just leave believe home
and be on the road all time and kind of
turn into like Groundhog Day
I knew if there are a lot of guys who
were 70 years out old and still out
there doing it yeah and you know those
guys usually have some serious issues
[Laughter]